hello everybody my name is markiplier
and Merry Christmas and all that you can
see I got my very festive Santa hat on
that detached by a USB cord Shh I didn't
know I Christmas snuck up on me I have
no idea so I'm here playing Gary snowing
secrets which is a Christmas special and
needs your custom story yes it exists so
I'm going to play this made by the same
guy that made Gary dark secrets haha
it's the day before Christmas and you're
enjoying a nice cup of tea next to your
Christmas tree what could be better then
suddenly someone knocks on your door who
could it be this late prepare yourself
for a little different amnesia adventure
ha ha ha oh that
ah nothing like drinking some hot tea
the day before Christmas next a
beautiful Christmas tree hmm
but there's something missing hmm ah yes
perfect jingle bell jingle bell Jingle
Bell Rock ah what but it's 10 o clock
who could it be this late that a clocks
out that leg jeez oh ok I'm playing now
I stood upright on the cos I was so
pissed
who could it be you present present
goodbye
boom ah well I had nothing in here I
guess I gotta answer to the proton yay
yeah Jenna rocket present ever
uh I love this gustav dory okay I guess
I better answer the door
ask her an audience with it alright now
hello hello who is it oh yes mr.
whatever-your-name-is because I don't
give a [ __ ] sorry
who the hell writes down a hell silence
this is my note and I do whatever I want
that's right all right jeez where was I
ah
yes my name is Santa Claus and I was
wondering if you would like to come over
and have some delicious cake with me
just follow the road outside your house
and you will find my castle the door is
unlocked and I will be waiting for you
in the living room okay yeah it sound
good huh
and he expects me to believe that he is
a real Santa Claus and this is not a
trap hmm maybe I should just go to
anyway throw a rock through his window
and yells something like a Santa you
suck
yeah that would be totally badass well
no time to waste
let's go wait I didn't get everything in
the house oh okay I could still go
that's absolute silliness and really
good voice acting too I'm actually quite
a surprise
because I remember in Giridhar Secrets
they didn't have like the best I mean it
was decent but not the best whoever was
Santa there was really good
my name is Gary and this is a note well
good job Gary Pradhan got it no give it
up present huh yeah brother give me the
rising yeah yeah okay nothing in here
what about this last one you know for
some reason I don't think that's
actually Santa I got a dinner set for
nobody cuz I'm all alone sacks and sacks
of potatoes alright I guess I'm out of
here huh off we go then to Santa's house
we surprisingly this USB cord connecting
this Santa hat totally realistic Santa
hat to my head isn't very comfortable
ahh
oh that's not what I remember the song
being
it seems rather diabolical now was that
my character going oh she's got it
awesome
wait a minute isn't this wrong sake
pants casa it's that old fart wrapper
your prank on me well you can forget
that let's see if we can find a nice big
rock somewhere uh okay
I don't think this is a good idea man
calm down who's just a note right where
is that big old rock let's see here oh I
know is just go haha huh ah you suck you
suck zoom ah oh hey hey you know hey you
dick
sirrah you do suck this is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever played but I
love that how you like me staying here
you like it's good pretty fluffy
Oh what is this madness
hahahahaha I did oh cool what is this
madness
haha Oh other funny is again heard
namida oh cool I love his mud I love it
I love it oh god I love this okay
no big lumps of coal No oh I see
here we go get all the way chairs help
yeah yeah pop yep oh good okay squeeze
in there
Oh God huh yeah good God
stuck huh yeah yeah look come on okay
huh huh huh
good God there we go ah balls yeah here
we go
I can squeeze through there can't I
can't I huh there we go geez that's
harder than I thought hello huh how
suspicious Lord sock pant how dare you I
am not to be toyed with
Boyle
we man
oh look all these Christmas eh wait a
minute hey I need something to throw
there how about this rock give me yeah
mush what oh yes
anything through there that I need I
need to go through there but what do I
need hit it with present present present
present
whoa bubbles oh it's like it's leading
me somewhere maybe I should be more
suspicious mmm
ah what what more Prez well hello Hans
oh it's good
hahaha Oh present in the fireplace James
the President and there are presents
everywhere
wait was that okay that's nothing oil
present present yeah I wish the presents
were like smashable x' and they have
dinner boxes in oil and ballast complete
the Christmas experience really get back
to the root to what Christmas is all
about
hello earlier today Santa Claus arrived
I was wondering if we could come in for
some cake I didn't believe him of course
but then he gave me a teddy bear and I
got really happy so I let him in and
that was probably the biggest mistake
I've ever made
that thing it was not Santa Claus
no monster really killed everyone I
locked me in here he told me this is
going to use me as a lifetime snack so I
guess this is it
my life will end tonight [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
sucks man anyone read this get out of
here before he finds you he's probably
very hungry about now when you read this
since I hardly have any flesh left of my
own money so with that said you're
screwed dude well [ __ ] you too man I'm
not screwed I'm a survivor
show yourself
I will rim the head off this teddy bear
no mr. teddy bear you get cute no not a
teddy bear no no but don't be stupid now
I can't let myself get fooled by freaks
there are tricky tricks on the other
hand I really want to save that too oh I
don't know should I save him or find
another way around hmm maybe there's
some secret stuff you're telling me I
actually have a choice here
ooh hang on I'll save you teddy bear
what's this
aha kachunk huh goodbye Oh
Oh teddy bear I will always remember
even though I never actually met you but
you will always be in my heart oh no not
the teddy bear complete malarkey hello
anybody home
no okay well what am i what am I
supposed to do about that I'm kind of
stuck here aren't I
Wow wait a minute no what what oh uh
hello
oh but that's obviously convenient hmm
oh hey no this is a remote in what why
hi what dick what i'ma go in a circle
couldn't I have just gone out and shaved
the teddy bear it was all for nothing
I didn't save the teddy bear I didn't
even say myself
Hey Oh aah
what hi
how did that happen I doesn't make any
sense at all
I still miss Hedy McPherson okay I'm
over it hello Santa I've been such a
good boy this year I'm looking forward
to your present yes hello oh this is
less Christmasy this is let more
diabolical what happened what happened
don't tell me I'm gonna get more lumps
of coal no no no yeah this kind of went
to classical am neat what shut up no my
rotten you didn't tell me guys ha ha
closing ha ha take that Santa yeah
it's closed I'm not looking back I make
the bad man take a look II back all the
time but didn't do that
Santa know don't get me any more call
he's got a shove call on my ass ah ha ha
made of the finest plywood I love this
guy I've ever makes disgusted oh
absolutely
this is nice Oh present present I don't
need this anymore
this is like made for a feast man oh
it's fantastic wheezes some in their new
ah a good thing you'll never get through
that door hi Deanna oh you look so jolly
pallid man who ever lived in this castle
with sock pants in your sock pants boy
he really knew how to live do more
brother hands I love it
yeah dream oh thank god it was just a
dream the wait that means it's Christmas
yeah time to open my princess yay that
you bought for yourself cuz you live
alone right yeah sure
yay gotta get dressed got to put my
clothes on what is this that's weird
okay yeah I'm going out naked merry
[ __ ] Christmas yeah how about dance
with me
tell me
right what
right
Hey okay
Ella's Gary DeLeo is Gary still he tells
awesome
that's better than a lot of customs toys
i played that had the best voice acting
I've ever heard near me as your custom
story and it was great it was hilarious
I'm glad I put that off because I saw
that a long time ago I was like uh-huh I
just didn't know it would be that
awesome so merry Christmas everyone
thank you for watching if you don't
celebrate Christmas Happy Holidays
whatever it is enjoy the spirit of the
season give be happy be merry so thank
you again and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye my son grow
this up kick crops grow up chickens eat
it eat it eat it
yeah jingle jingle bells go to hell
[ __ ] get out of my way Oh
but I'm not done